deuxième budget du ministre eric girard
à québec un budget qui annonce un
surplus encore une fois 2 milliards 700
millions avant le versements au fonds
des générations
après un surplus de 4 milliards 500
millions lors de l'exercice précédent
surplus malgré une perte dans la cseries
de 600 millions c'est assez jovialiste
quand même comme budget parce que nous
savons ce qui se passe présentement avec
le coronavirus sa crise pétrolière
le ministre prévoit une croissance
économique de 2% du produit intérieur
brut en 2020 la plupart des économistes
du secteur privé s'attendent
probablement à la moitié de cela autour
de 1%
donc certainement que ce budget devra
être révisée ou en tout cas des sommes
supplémentaires devront être investis
dans l'économie pour tenter de stimuler
l'économie
si bien sûr le ralentissement est
important taudis beaucoup d'argent en
infrastructures 16 milliards de plus sa
porte le programme québécois en
infrastructures à plus de 130 milliards
de dollars
on devance des dépenses on met à l'étude
le rem jusqu'à laval avec un lien
également sos et on met à l'étude
également leur m jusqu'à chambly et
saint-jean-sur-richelieu beaucoup
d'investissements dans le secteur
routier pour le maintien du secteur
routier ce sont des engagements fermes
dans le transport collectif est encore
beaucoup de choses à attacher bien sûr
en termes de financement mais ayant un
intérêt un engagement du gouvernement
investir davantage dans le transport
collectif de l'argent également pour
rouler vers la réduction des gaz à effet
de serre pour les véhicules lourds
on continue de baisser la taxe scolaire
ça va se faire en juillet santé
éducation de l'argent dans l'émission
vraiment de l'état notamment pour les
aînés les jeunes en difficulté des
places en garderie le soutien aux
entreprises également qui est bonifiée
avec un crédit à l'innovation et 450
millions de dollars en six ans pour la
culture le secteur de la musique les
séries télé et les bâtiments
patrimoniaux
mais à moyen terme le gouvernement sur
le plan structurel devra trouver une
façon de réduire ses dépenses par
rapport à ses revenus augmenter ses
revenus
parce qu'en ce moment les dépenses
augmentent beaucoup plus rapidement que
les revenus